[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم زين
العابدين توفيق وبينما تحدثوا معكم الان
تقع احداث وتتفاعل اخرى الخرطوم ادي صور
مباشره للمدينه التي تعيش على واقع
المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع لليوم التاسع عشر على الثواني
وهذه صور مباشره في الولايات المتحده بعد
حادثه اطلاق نار عوده بحياه شخص واصابه
اربعه اخرين في احد المراكز الطبيه حادث
يعيد للوجه قضيه حيازه الاسلحه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
في روايه روسيه احباط هجوم بمسيرات على
الكرملين والهدف واغتيال بوتين بتدبير
اوكراني موسكو تتوعد بالرد يقول ان خيار
تصفيه
في اي صله لها وتحذر من استغلال الحادث
لشل هجوم روسي واسع عليها
[موسيقى]
مع استمرار اشتباكات الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع في محيط القصر الرئاسي وسط
الخرطوم الجيش يعلن موافقته على مبادره
الايجاد لتمديد الهدنه سبعه ايام وافادي
ممثل لبحث الهدنه وليس للتفاوض على انهاء
النزاع واحمد يؤكد التزامه بفتح الممرات
الانسانيه وضمان سلامه مرور المساعده
[موسيقى]
ومع استمرار المعارك وفوض الامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه يزور السودان ويؤكد
الحاجه لدعم دولي اضافي لمواجهه الازمه
الانسانيه ويقول للجزيره انه تواصل مع
البرهان وحميتي وطالبهما بضمانات بشان
سلامه وصول المساعده
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه تناولنا الحديث عن استهداف
الكرملين بمسيرات موسكو قالت ان الهجوم تم
احباطه فيما تواصلت اتداعيات والتصريحات
على مدار اليوم بين وعيد روسي ونفي
اوكراني وتشكيك امريكي
والاستطاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي كيف يغير
استهداف الكرملين مشهد الحربي في اوكرانيا
36 بالمئه من متابعين توقعوا هجوما روسيا
واسعا بين براءه 28% امكانيه استهداف
المباشرنسكي وحكومته وقال 36% انما حدث لا
يغير شيء في المشهد
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات
الرقميه ويمكن دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز الكيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
[موسيقى]
قلب موسكو واهم رموزها يتعرض لهجوم
بمسيرتين تقول موسكو انهما اوكرانيا هي
ضربه ترى اوساط في داخل روسيا وخارجها
انها معنويه اكثر منها عسكريه ضربه كسرت
هيبه موسكو المعروفه بانها من اكثر
المناطق المحصنه عسكريا في البلاد تضع
موسكو الحادثه في خانه العمليات الارهابيه
وتقول انها محاوله باغتيال الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين الذي لم يكن في المكان
لحظه وقوع الحادث
الهجوم شكلهم من اشكال الحرب النفسيه
والاعلاميه الدعائيه هدفها اظهار عدم
فعاليه المنظومه العسكريه الروسيه في صد
الهجمات الاوكرانيه اوكرانيا لا تستطيع
تحقيق نجاحات عسكريه على الارض وحتى
الاعلام الغربي بات يشكك في امكاناتها
بعيدا جديد
حسب مراقبين الكرملين يتواعد بالرد في
المكان والزمان المناسبين مسؤولون الروس
يعتبرون ما حدث هجوما مباشرا يستهدف
الرئيس الروسي ما يستدعي تصفيه القياده
الاوكرانيه حسب تعبيرهم فيما ذهب نائب
رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
الى ابعد من ذلك ليوشيرا الى ان الامر كما
كان في عهد هتلر لم يعد بحاجه الى توقيع
زيلينسكي على وثيقه الاستسلام
حدث ترافق مع زياده وتيره استهداف المنشات
الروسيه من قبل الجانب الاوكراني في
المناطق الحدوديه واعلان اعتقال شبكه
عملاء تابعه للاستخبارات الاوكرانيه في
القرن وضلوع شخصيه رفيعه في مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني في تنظيم اعمال ارهابيه في
روسيا والتخطيط لاغتيال مسؤولين الروس كل
ذلك يهدد بانتقال المواجهه في اوكرانيا
الى مستوى اخر وقد يشكل حجه بحسب العديد
من المراقبين لذهاب روسيا الى ابعد مما
يسمى العمليه العسكريه هي قنبله رمزيه
فجرت قنبله بلغت الكرملين قلب موسكو
السياسيه والشعبي بانتظار شكل الرد الروسي
وحجمه على هذه الضربه المعنويه غير
المسبوقه في تاريخ روسيا راني دريدي
الجزيره موسكو
وبعد التفاعلات السياسيه والموقف الروسي
الذي نقلته والزميل رانيا دريدي نتابع
تفاصيل هذا الهجوم ومواقع سقوط المسيرات
المهاجمه وايضا الفرضيات المختلفه عن
اماكن انطلاقها في سياق هذا التقرير
[موسيقى]
قال الكريم انه حدث بعد منتصف الليل
والمكان المستهدف احد مباني الكرمنين في
المنطقه المطله على الس
احه والمغلقه بشكل كامل استعدادا لعرض
عسكري بمناسبه عيد النصر في التاسع مما
يغير الحالي ويظهر ان اجهزه الحمايه
الفيدراليه استطاعت رصد المسيرات واسقاطها
لكن اين كان الرئيس بوتين عند وقوع الهجوم
المتحرك الرسمي باسم الكرملين قال انه كان
موجودا بمقر اقامته بضواحي موسكو فينوفا
اوغاريوفا ولم يصاب باي اذى ولم يتغير
جدول اعماله هيئه الطوارئ الروسيه اعلنت
ايضا سقوط طائره مسيره اخرى في مدينه
كولوم في ضواحي موسكو وتبعد نحو 110
كيلومترات تقريبا عن موسكو من غير الواضح
من اين اتت المسيرات وخاصه ان روسيا اتهمت
كييف صراحه بالمسؤوليه عن الهجوم لكن
بالنظر لطبيعه الانفجار وحجمه رجحت
تحريرات مختلفه ان تكون المسيرتان اطلقه
من داخل موسكو من مسافه قريبه يصعب على
الرادارات رصدها وتبقى فرضيه القدوم من
خارج الحدود والده ولكن ضئيله وفق محللين
اذ في حال اعت ان هذه الطائرات انطلقت من
اقرب نقطه جغرافيه في اوكرانيا في شمال
السومي فيجب ان تكون قادره على التحليق
لمسافه تصل لنحو 600 كم دون كشفها وهذا
امر صعب
[موسيقى]
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي بعد
كل ما استمعنا اليه هل يمكن معرفه على
الاقل نوع هذه الطائرات التي تقول روسيا
ناس استهدفت وكان الهدف من ورائها اغتيال
بوتين
يا سيدي عن الان لا يوجد معلومات لانه لم
تقدم معلومات واذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن
الطائرات في المسيره هناك المئات من انواع
الطائرات المسيره وهي تتدرج من من حجم
صغير جدا
حتى تصل الى مسيرات تقطع مسافه عشره الاف
كيلو متر من مسيرات تحمل واحد كيلو جرام
متفجرات الى سيارات تحمل صواريخ وبالتالي
ما لم يقدم معلومه دقيقه عن
الطائره الثالثه التي تم العثور عليها
نبقى نتحدث في اطار الفرضيات وبالتالي هذه
الطائرات تستخدم لاغراض تجاريه تستخدم
لايصال البريد والاستقداء طلبات الدليفري
في في بعض المناطق على سبيل المثال
الفيديو التي تم تداولها ونحن نشاهد هذه
النيران التي تلتهم هذه الطائره حينما
اقتربت من القبه قبه الكريملين هل يمكن
القول ان هذه الطائرات كانت محمله بذخائر
ام لا
يا سيدي الان يعني تابعنا الفيديو
واكثر من مره
الملاحق انه كانت الطائره يعني تم مشاهده
الطائره القادمه ومن ثم حصر الانفجار في
اللحظه الاولى او في المشاهد الاولى كنا
نتوقع انه اصاب الاداء لكن بعد ذلك تبين
ان ساريه العلم والعلم لم يتضرر وبالتالي
هذا يفتح باب التكهنات الكثيره جدا حول
مصدر الطائر لماذا لانه لو كانت الطائره
قادمه من اوكرانيا فوسائل التعامل معها
مختلفه اولا الدفاع الجوي استخدام الليزر
استخدام عمليات التشويش واستخدام
المقاربات
الالكترونيك وهناك بنادق خاصه لكن هناك
اتهام اوكراني اخر يتهم سواء روسيا كمؤسسه
كدوله او الرديكاليان الراديكاليين الروس
وبالتالي اذا كان
الاتهام الاوكراني دقيقا فبالتالي اليه
التخلص من الطائره مختلفه هنا تكون من
خلال استخدام فيوزات
بدل ان يكون فيوز الصادم يعتمد على
الاصطدام بالهدف يمكن استخدام نوع اخر
يسمى الفلوس التقاربي الذي تستطيع ان تحدد
متى ينفجر وعلى اي مسافه ينفجر وعلى اي
ارتفاع ينفجر وبالتالي مع ان الاتهامات
متبادله يعني لا نستطيع لكن الانفجار الذي
حصل لم يتم من خلال انا لم اشاهد صاروخ
اتجه باتجاهها قد يكون يمكن ان يكون قناص
الليزر طيب يعني هذا سؤال كبير من ضمن
الاسئله الكثيره التي طرحت لكن هنالك سؤال
اخر خاص بالتحصينات العسكريه لحمايه موسكو
لاسيما من الهجمات الجويه سنسال هذا
السؤال فايز لكن بعد ان نتعرف على
التحصينات عموما في موسكو في هذا العرض
[موسيقى]
احدى اكثر عواصم العالم تحصينا عاده ما
تحمي القوى الكبرى مراكز صنع قرارها
بتحصينات متعدده المستويات تحيط روسيا
عاصمتها بدرع صاروخيه لاعتراض اي هجمات
بصواريخ نوويه او استراتيجيه وحول موسكو
تتوزع منظومات دفاعيه ابرزها منظومه اس
400 التي يصفها خبراء عسكريون بانها من
بين الافضل ضمن منظومات الدفاع الجوي وهي
نظام متنقل قادر على كشف الاهداف الجويه
على بعد 400 كيلومتر والتصدي لثمانين هدفا
منها في وقت واحد عن طريق توجيه صاروخين
ارض جو لكل هدف منظومه اس 300 وهي مصممه
للتصدي للطائرات المهاجمه وللصواريخ طويله
المدى مثل صواريخ كروز ويمكنها اعتراض 24
طائره او 16 صاروخا باليستيا حتى مسافه
كيلو مترا في وقت واحد
تحمي روسيا مواقعها الحيويه والحساسه
بمنظومات دفاع قصيره المدى كمنظومه
التي توصف بانها حاميه سماء موسكو وهي
قادره على رصد وتدمير الاهداف الجويه على
مدى 20 كيلومترا تمتلك بانسر اس واحد 12
صاروخا وكذلك مدفعين اوتوماتيكيين
يستخدمان ضد الذخائر النفاثه والصواريخ
والى جانب دفاعاتها الصاروخيه تتخذ روسيا
اجراءات لحمايه قلب موسكو وتحديدا مقر
القياده السياسيه للبلاد الكرملين اذ تعطل
السلطات الروسيه انظمه ملاحه الجويه
والارضيه وكافه الاتصالات خلال تحركات
الرئيس والصف الاول من القياده ومنذ بدايه
الحرب في اوكرانيا تحضر السلطات الروسيه
تحليق الطائرات المسيره بكافه انواعها في
سماء موسكو ارضا وجوا وبحرا وحتى في
العالم الافت تضرب روسيا طوقا يقيها اي
هجمات معاديه معطيات تفرض تساؤلا بشان كيف
تجاوزت طائرات مسيره هذا الطوق ووصلت الى
قلب روسيا ومركز قرارها
اذا تحسنت كثيره لموسكو شانها واشنطن مثلا
في الولايات المتحده ومع ذلك كان هنالك
هجمات او على الاقل مسيرات استطاعت ان
تقترب من البيت الابيض لواء فايز هل يمكن
منع المسيرات رغم كل هذه التحصينات
والانظمه الدفاعيه
يا سيدي اولا كلمه مطلق غير موجوده الامن
المطلق غير موجود
وحتى افضل انواع معدات الدفاع الجوي ومنها
الاس 400 والذي يعتبر متقدما على
صواريخ فان لان فيه ميزه تختلف حيث
الصواريخ الاربعه كل صاروخ يتعامل مع مدى
حتى في نفسه عربه الاطلاق تتعامل مع اربعه
مدايات
متباينه وبالتالي هناك كما اشارت تقييم
اكثر من منظومه اكثر من منظومه لكن حتى في
افضل المنظومات لا توجد منظومه تقدم لك
نسبه امان مطلقه ميه بالميه قد ترقى الى
90% قد ترقى 92% يبقى احتماليه الفشل
والفشل يكون من احد ثلاثه مرتكزات عدم
الكشف وعدم الكشف قد يكون خطا اعتق خطا
بشري عدم ايصال المعلومه من منظومات
الرادار الى القياده والسيطره المسؤوله عن
ترجمه ذلك الى اوامر اطلاق وعدم وصول
الامر من مركز القياده والسيطره الى
الجماعه المنفذه وبالتالي لانه هذه تعمل
ضمن حلقه من ثلاثه نقاط رئيسيه وبالتالي
قد يكون الخلل صدر من اين من هذه
المرتكزات الثلاثه الى ذلك الان اذا كانت
الطائره قادمه من العمق الاوكراني وهذا
مشكوك فيه بسبب حجم الطائره الطائره هذه
لا تذهب الى مئات الكيلومترات ولكن لنفرض
جدلا انها الثالثه سقطت على بعد 110 كيلو
متر هذه المسافه والطائره الطائرات
المسيره الى صغيره الحجم طبيعه المعدن
المشروعه منه طبيعه الدهار المستخدم هذا
هذا المثلث
صغر الحجم والدهان ونوع المعدن يقلل او
قيمه ما يطلق عليها البصمه الحراريه وهي
امكانيه اكتشافها من قبل الرادار هنا يمكن
ان تخترق
نعم شكرا جزيلا
الخبير العسكري
في ردود الفعل نبدا باول المتهمين والحديث
عن كييف حيث نفى الرئيس الاوكراني
اي علاقه لبلاده بالهجوم وقال خلال مؤتمر
صحفي مشترك فيه هيلسنكي مع نظرائه في دول
الشمال اوروبا قال ان بلاده تحارب على
اراضيها ولا تهاجمه بوتين او موسكو
لا نهاجم بوتين ولا موسكو نحاربه على
ارضنا وندافع عنها لا نملك كما تعلمون
اسلحه كافيه لتنفيذ هذه الهجمات لذلك لا
نستخدمها في اي مكان ولا نسمح لانفسنا
بهدرها لم نهاجم سنترك الامر للقضاء
هذا واكد مسؤول رفيع في الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه انه لا علاقه لبلاده بالهجوم
الذي استهدف واعتبر المسؤول ان الهجوم لا
يحقق شيئا ولا يغير الموقف في ارض المعركه
باوكرانيا كما قال وابدا المسئول
الاوكراني قالقه من ان الهجوم قد يدفع
روسيا لاتخاذ اجراءات اكثر تشددا تجاه
اوكرانيا قال ان الهجوم يشي بان موسكو
تخطط لهجوم ارهابي واسع النطاق على بلاده
في الايام المقبله
وفي واشنطن نقلت عن مصادر الامريكيه انها
تعمل على تحليل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
متضمنه صور اقمار اصطناعيه واتصالات تم
اعتراضها للحصول على ادله بشان ما حدث في
موسكو وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
تنتظر ظهور الحقائق لكنه اضاف ان من غير
الممكن تاكيد صحه الروايه الروسيه حاليا
اطلعت على التقارير لكن لا يمكنني تاكيد
صحتها باي شكل من الاشكال فنحن ببساطه لا
نعرف كما انني اتعامل مع اي شيء يصدر من
الكرملين بقدر كبير من الشك لذلك دعونا
ننتظر ظهور الحقائق ومن الصعب حقا التعليق
او التكهني بشان هذا الامر دون معرفه
الحقائق لكن بشكل عام وكما ذكرنا فانه
عندما يتعلق الامر باوكرانيا التي تتعرض
للاعتداء اليومي وتتعرض قواتها العسكريه
الشجاعه ومواطنوها للاعتداء يوميا جراء
هذا العدوان الروسي فاننا نترك لاوكرانيا
ان تقرر كيف ستدافع عن نفسها وكيف ستحاول
استعاده الاراضي التي استولت عليها روسيا
رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس ومن كييف
مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه السابق
ومدير برنامج العلاقات الخارجيه والامن
الدوليه في مركز رازون كوفلي الدراسات
نبدا بضيفنا بكلانو من موسكو ما الادله
التي قدمت من جانب روسيا حتى الان على
زعمها بان هذا هجوم لاغتيال بوتين شخصيا
وهو هجوم اوكراني
حقيقه الامر هذه هي فقط البدايه بدايه
للعمل المتصل الذي يهدف الى فهم جوهر هذا
الحدث لكن
التحقيق الاولي
اعطانا بعض الادله والتي اشارتها على انها
كانت ان اوكرانيا كانت وراء هذا الهجوم
لكن الاهم من ذلك انه خلاله هذه الايام
كان هنالك الكثير من الامثله الامثله لمثل
هذه الهجمات على اراضي القرم وايضا في
اماكن اخرى حيث كان هنالك بعض العناصر من
الاوكرانيين ومن المرتبطين باوكرانيا
والذين كانوا والذين يعملون لصالح
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه والذ قاموا
بالتخطيط
لبعض الاعتداءات ضد الروس بالتالي نحن
نعتقد في موسكو ان هذه فقط
حادثه من عده
حصلت في السابق
عملا يعني فريدا في حد ذاته وانما هنالك
شواهد سابقه على هجمات سابقه من الجانب
الاوكراني في موسكو بحسب الزعم الروسي لان
اوكرانيا لم تزعم ابدا المسؤوليه عن اي
هجوم حصل على الاراضي الروسيه لكنها لم
تنفي كل الهجمات وهنا اسال
لم تنفي اوكرانيا كل ما حدث في روسيا على
اراضي روسيه ولا اتحدث عن القرم تحديدا
نتحدث عن داخل الروسي هنالك كثير من
الاحداث التي وقعت منها مثلا تعطيل شبكه
السكه الحديد قبل احتفالات يوم النصر لم
تنفي اوكرانيا مسؤوليتها عن ذلك لم تنفي
مسؤوليات اخرى احداث اخرى لم تنفي عنها عن
نفسها الماسوريه لكن هذا هو الحدث ربما
الاول او من الاحداث النادر التي تقول
اوكرانيا بشكل واضح لا لم نفعل ذلك كيف
تفسر ذلك
في حقيقه الامر عاده
المسؤولوك ينفون مسؤوليتهم على اي هجمات
تحصل في الاراضي الروسيه وفي بعض الاحيان
يكون من الواضح ان هذه الهجمات قامت بها
عناصر من القوات الخاصه الاوكرانيه او
ربما اشخاص من نتحدث ربما عن هجماتي
مسيرات على منشات الوقود لكن في موسكو انا
لست متاكدا ان
مئه بالمئه ان هذا الهجوم كانت وراءه
اوكرانيا ربما كان مسؤولا عنه شخص داخل
روسيا او عناصر اخرى
لكن لماذا تستبعد ان تكون عناصر اوكرانيه
ايضا
كما ذكرت سابقا
هذه استراتيجيه تواصل تستخدمها الحكومه
الاوكرانيه
عمليه نفي قد يكون الامر معتادا في حاله
الحرب لكن كل الاهداف هي اهداف مشروعه
ولربما ايضا ساشير انه لا يكون هنالك اي
خسائر مدنيه وهذا اعتقد اننا يجب ان نتذكر
هذا الامر عندما تحاول روسيا ان تقوم بوصف
اوكرانيا او هذه الهجمات على انها هجمات
ارهابيه طيب اعود الى بكلانوف ما هي
المصلحه اذا اذا كانت روسيا تصررها لنا
هذا هجوم اوكرانيا ما هي المصلحه التي
تحققها اوكرانيا بمثل هذا الهجوم الذي لم
يحقق اي فائده عسكريه وفي الواقع قد ياتي
برد فعل عنيف جدا من موسكو
في حقيقه الامر
زي
منشورتينا اغلبيه
الشخصيات السياسيه التي تحدثت اليوم
قالوا ان اجراءات معينه سيتم اتخاذها من
قبل الجانب الروسي لكن بدايه يجب ان يكون
هنالك تحقيق اكثر وادله اكثر يتم شرحها
وقرار تم اتخاذه من قبل الحكومه ان
اجراءات انتقاميه ستحصل في الوقت والمكان
المناسبين بالتالي على ان سيكون هنالك وقت
معين حيث ستكون هنالك اجراءات يتم وضعها
وتطبيقها
شكرا جزيلا لك من موسكو
ضيفنا السفير اندريه باك لانوسيين الروس
ونشكر ضيفنا من كيف ملك
مساعد وزير الدفاع الاوكرانيه السابقه
المسيرات كانت ابرز الحاضرين في مشهد
الهجوم اليوم حضور يعيد للوجه حجم التغيير
الذي احدثته هذه الطائره المسيره في انماط
الحروب
[موسيقى]
الى السودان افاد مراسل الجزيره بتجدد
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
في محيط القصر الرئاسي بالخرطوم اضاف
مراسلنا ان الطائرات الحربيه قصفت مواقع
للدعم السريع في منطقه شرق النيل بالخرطوم
بحري وان مضادات الدعم السريع ردت على
القصف وقالت قوات الدعم السريع من ناحيه
اخرى انها تصدت لهجوم على مواقعها من قوات
شرطه الاحتياطيه المركزي وسط الخرطوم
وفي تفاصيل اكثر للمشهد خلال الساعات
الماضيه الاشتباكات العنيفه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع تواصلت في محيط القصر
الرئاسي وسط العاصمه السودانيه مرسل
الجزيره فهذا بان المقاتلات قصفت مواقع
للدعم السريع في منطقه شرق النيل بالخرطوم
بحري وردت عليها وحدات الدعم السريع
بالمضادات الارضيه
كما قالت قوات الدعم السريع عندها تصدت
لهجوم على مواقعها من قوات شرطه
الاحتياطيه المركزي وسط الخرطوم
ومن وسط الخرطوم ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
هيثم عويتس هيثم مجمل التطورات العسكريه
في هذا اليوم اليوم التاسع عشر
للمواجهات بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني
نعم ميدانيه اليوم كان يوما ساخنا ايضا من
تاريخ هذه المواجهات المستمره منذ نحو
ثلاثه اسابيع حتى الان كانت هناك مواجهات
عنيفه وقويه في محيط القصر الرئاسي وايضا
في منطقه وسط الخرطوم تحديدا في منطقه
السوق العربي هذه المنطقه التي دارت فيها
اشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
وكانت الطائرات الحربيه تابعه للجيش
السوداني تقصف العديد من المواقع التي
تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم السريع هذه
المعركه استمرت لساعات طويله بدات منذ
الصباح
بمناوشات خفيفه سرعان ما تحولت الى يعني
مواجهات قويه وعنيفه في وسط الخرطوم وايضا
امتدت الى منطقه شرق النيل حيث كانت هناك
ايضا
الطائرات الحربيه تقصف بعض المواقع في شرق
النيل التابعه لقوات الدعم مع السريع هذه
تعتبر المواجهات المعتاده
المواجهات اه يعني هذه هذا لا جديد فيها
فيما يبدو لكن فيما يتعلق بشرطه الاحتياطي
المركزي الذي تقول قوات الدعم السريع انها
تصدت هجوما الاها نريد ان نعرف هذا العنصر
الذي دخل الى المعركه كيف دخل من اين جاء
معلومات عن شرطه الاحتياط المركزي
بحسب بيان الداخليه وزاره الداخليه قبل
ايام انها كانت قد قامت بنشر هذه القوات
من اجل تامين الممتلكات العامه وتامين
حمايه الناس في الشوارع في الطرقات العامه
خاصه بعد انتشار الجريمه في السودان نتيجه
لهذه
المواجهات الامنيه وحاله السيوله الامنيه
الحاصله نتيجه لانتشار المعارك ولكن اليوم
هذه
القوه بحسب بيان نظرته قوات الشرطه
الاحتياطي المركزي انها ان لديها كانت قوه
او دوريه شرطه كانت تقوم بعمل دوريه في
منطقه السوق العربي وتعرضت لهجوم بحسب
البيان من قبل اربع سيارات تتبع لقوات
الدعم السريع وانهم وان هذه الدوريه كانوا
بها خمسه اشخاص قتلوا جميعا جراء هذه
المواجهات هذا بيان
الشرطه ولكن بيان القوات الدعم السريع كان
غير ذلك تحدث عن ان هناك قوه هاجمت
تمركز قوات الدعم السريع من الجيش
وتتقدمها ايضا قوات الشرطه ايضا يعني بحسب
البيان ان هناك كان مختلطه ما بين الجيش
والشرطه الاحتياطي المركزي وبالتالي هي
كانت اعلنت في وقت سابق انها اصبحت هذه
القوات هدفا لها لانها دخلت الى المعرفه
شكرا جزيلا لك هيثم من وسط الخرطوم
هذا واكد دفع الله الحاج علي المبعوث
الخاص لرئيس مجلس السياده السودانيه انه
لا تفاوض مباشره مع قوه الدعم السريع
واضاف في اعقاب لقاءات اجراها في السعوديه
ومصر ان الحل النهائي للازمه الحاليه في
السودان يكونوا من خلال الحسم العسكري
موافقه حكومه السودان عن الهدنه فقط وليست
على اي وساطه فيما يتعلق بالوضع
النهائي لهذا النزاع لان هذا النزاع تمرد
على القوات المسلحه السودانيه من فصيل كان
يتبع لها
الحل النهائي بالنسبه لنا والحسبه العسكري
لن تكون هنالك
مخاطبه او لقاء مباشر مع وفدنا مع وفد
الحركه المتمرده
وانما الميسرين وهما الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
سيتواصلون وينقلون الرؤى وانا
في سياق
التوصل لهذه الهدنه
هذا وقنا المتحدث باسم الجيش السوداني ان
الجيش وفقع على مقترح منظمه ايجاد بشان
الازمه في البلاد ويترخص في تمديد الهدنه
الحاليه لمده اسبوع وتسميه ممثل للتباحث
مع الاليه الرفيعه المستوى المكونه من
رؤساء الدول دوله جنوب السودان وكينيا
وجيبوتي على ان يجري هذا الحوار في دوله
يتم التوافق عليها مع هذه الاليه واكد
النطق الرسمي ان موافقه القوات المسلحه
على المقترح تاتي انطلاقا من مبدا الحلول
الافريقيه ومراعاه للجوانب الانسانيه مع
اخذ المبادره الامريكيه السعوديه بعين
الاعتبار
من في الاستوديو والكاتب والمحلل السياسي
السوداني ضياء الدين بلال هذا التصريح
للمتحدث العسكري وراينا تصريح دفعل الحاج
علي مبعوث البرهان الى السعوديه والى مصر
ما الذي نقراه في البيانين واضح ان هنالك
اطراف في الموقف الرسمي الجيش المعبر عنه
فيما يتعلق بالهدنه وبما يتعلق بالتفاوض
وهنالك تصريحات تخرج من ياسر من السيد
الفريق ياسر العطا يتحدث عن عدم وجود
تفاوض تماما وهنالك تصريحات تخرج من
الكباش الفريق الكباشي يتحدث عن هدنه
متعلقه فقط بالجوانب الانسانيه
فيبدو ان هنالك اضطراب فيما يتعلق بهذه
خاصه وان الهدن والمقترحات والمبادرات
المقدمه مبادرات متعدده هنالك مبادره
امريكيه ومبادره افريقيه ومبادره عربيه
فيبدو ان زحام هذه المبادرات ادى الى
اضطراب الموقف الحكومي اتجاه التعامل مع
المقترحات المتعلقه بالهدنه او متعلقه
رساله الحسم كلمه الحسم انه نهائي النزايه
يكون بالحسم العسكري جاءت في الواقع على
لسان مبعوث البرهان الى القاهره والى
السعوديه السيد دفع الله الحاج علي ماذا
نفهم من ذلك ربما المقصود بالحسم هو هو
اخلاء المواقع الاستراتيجيه التي سيطر
عليها الدعم السريع في الساعات الاولى من
الصراع الدعم السريع يسيطر على عدد من
المواقع التي كان يحرسها في الاساس
فبالتالي لا يستطيع الجيش ان يجلس الى
التفاوض وهذه الاماكن الاستراتيجيه
والحساسه في يد الدعم السريع لان ذلك
سيعضد من وضع الدعم السريع وهو يقدم له
ميزه تفضيليه على الخصمه الاخر اللي هو
الجيش فبالتالي لا اعتقد ان الجيش سيقبل
بهذا الامر ما لما
تخلى هذه المناطق وواضحه
حتى قبل بدا هذه الاشتباكات نعم هو استولى
على هذه المناطق التي كان يحرسها وغدر
بالذين كانوا مع
ان دورها دور التاميني ولكن يبدو ان الدعم
السريع اراضي استهداف هذه القوه لانه عاجز
عن مواجهه الجيش مواجهه الجيش
الجيش خاصه فيما يتعلق باستخدام الطائرات
الى الان الدعم السريع لا يملك مضادات
للطائرات حتى يقلل من فاعليه هذه هذه
الطائرات فبالتالي هو يستهدف هذه
المجموعات وهي مجموعات مسلحه تسليح خفيف
وليس تسليح ثقيل كما الدعم السريع وكما
كما الجيش فاعتقد ان الاستهداف استهداف
استهداف النقاط الهشه والنقاط الضعيفه لان
الدعم السريع عاجز عن التعامل مع الخسائر
الكبيره التي تلحق بها عبر الطيران الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي شكرا لك
وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان اهلا وسهلا بك
سياده الوزير ما هي الردود التي جاءتكم
حتى الان على مبادره
الايجاد التي يعني تتكون من جنوب السودان
وايضا من رئيس
كينيا جيبوتي
اشكركم على الاستضافه في هذا المساء انا
ممتن
لاعطاء الوقت
للتحدث عما يحصل في السودان عن طريق
مبادره الايجاد لحد الان لم نتلقى رسميا
اي رد لكن راينا اليوم الجيش يرد على
مبادره الايكات عن طريق قبولي بوقف
الاطلاق النار لسبعه ايام اضافيه وهل في
رايكم هذا رد كاف
هذه خطوه مرحب بها لانها روح تعبر عن روح
جيده
وايضا قوات الدعم السريع يجب ان تقوم تقطع
الصوت
يبدو انه الصوت انقطع مع السيد
اعيد السؤال مره اخرى كنت اقول ان كان هذا
الرد من جانب الجيش السوداني بقبول فقط
الهدنه دون التفاوض مع الطرف الاخر
بالنسبه لكم يعتبر ردا كافيا وقلت انه
مقدمه جيده او خطوه يمكن الترحيب بها لكن
هل هو كافي
خطوه تعبر عن الروح الجيده لان وقف اطلاق
النار مهمه جدا للسودان هذا الامر يعني ان
الجيش وقوات الدعم
عن القتال وهذا الامر مهم جدا لتحقيق اي
اتفاق يخص السودان اذا ما بالتالي هذا
الاعلان من الجيش هذا تطور مرحب به ونريد
في نفس الوقت من قواتي الدعم السريع ان
تقوم
بامرنا مشابه
وايضا القائد
الجنرال احمد ايضا ان يقوم بنفس الشيء من
فهمكم لوضع الان في السودان هل تعتقدون ان
الطرفين فعلا جاهزان لوقف القتال بشكل
دائم والتفاوض هل الظروف مناسبه بالنسبه
لهما
ليس لدي اي شيء من ان هذا هو الوقت
المناسب لهم لكي يقبلوا
وخاصه خلال ايقاف القتال لقد دعانا الشعب
السوداني بشكل كبير او خاصه من يسكن في
الخرطوم لقد شاهدوا ملم يروه في السابق في
حياتهم وسيكون هذا مبادره حسنه من قبل
الجيش ومن قبل قوات الدعم السريع هل
تلقيتم اي تفضيلات لمكان اللقاء سواء لقاء
المندوبين او اذا حدث لاحقا وتم لقاء بين
البرهان وحميدتي هل تلقيتهم تفضيلات من
الجانبين لهذا لمكان هذا اللقاء هل هو
الجوبا هل هو عاصمه افريقيه اخرى هل هو
السعوديه ام غير ذلك
اي شرط يتعلق بمكان اللقاء
الصوت يتقطع بامكاني ان نتحل مشاكل
افريقيا في داخل افريقيا ونحن ايضا لدينا
اذا ما ارادوا ان يعقدوا اي اجتماع في اي
مكان اخر فنحن مستعدين الجنوب السودان
عرضت ان تكون جوبا محل اللقاء لانها قريبه
من الجنوب وتم عقد اتفاق سلام سابق فيها
وربما ستكون فرح سنكون فرحين
بالاشراف على هذا الامر بالتالي الخيار
مفتوح وسيتم الترحيبه من قبلنا بالنسبه
لمبادره التي تتبنونها هل هي يعني تفاوض
مفتوح على غير ذي اساس بغير شروط ام ان
لديكم فهما لما يجري في السودان وبناء على
هذا الفهم هنالك على الاقل اطار عام لهذا
التفاوض هنالك نقاط اساسيه خطوط معينه
مقاربتها واستراتيجيتنا هو ان نترك الحل
للشعب السوداني طرفي طرفاء الصراع القوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم العسكري وايضا قد
تنخرط قوه
سياسيه اخرى يجب ان يكون الحال بين قوات
الدعم السريع وبين الجيش السلام المستدام
ياتي من الناس انفسهم ايجاد لا يمكنها ان
تضع شروطا مسبقا لكنها تقوم بتسهيل
اللقاء بين قوات الدعم السريع وقائد الجيش
وقائد قوات الدعم السريع يعني هنالك
مقاربتان لما يجري في السودان ان هنالك
مقاربه الدعم السريع ومقاربه الجيش الجيش
يقول نحن جيش الدوله النظامي وانما حدث
تمرد على الدوله كيف توصفون انتم ما يجري
في السودان
المرحله لا يمكننا ان نتحدث عن هذا الامر
نعرف ان قوات المسلحه السودانيه هي القوات
الشرعيه اللي البلد لكن في نفس الوقت فان
قوات الدعم السريع قد اصبحت
وحده برلمانيه في السودان بالتالي الان لا
يمكننا ان اعلق على هذا الامر فنريد ان
نقوم به هو ان نعطيه منصه بامكان الطرفين
فيها ان يتحدث وبالتالي
باستطاعتنا ان نرى ونحدد بعد ذلك من هو
الذي يتسم بالشرعيه ومن لا يتسم بالشرعيه
وزير الخارجيه جنوب السودان من نيروبي
دينك شكرا جزيلا لك
ومع تفاقم الازمه الانسانيه في انحاء
السودان بفعل استمرار لمواجهات المسلحه
لليوم التاسع عشر اكد مفوض الامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه
السودان الى دعم اضافي رغم جمع 200 مليون
دولار
اضافث في مقابله مع الجزيره انه طلب من
قائدي الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع ضمانات
بشان سلامه وصول المساعده الانسانيه
في حياه الناس تراه
للقتال اثر بالغ في واقعهم المعيشي واضح
ان الارقام المتلاحقه عن التداعيات
الانسانيه لمواجهات المسلحه في السودان
حفزت جهدا اكبر للمجتمع الدولي
هكذا تعلن الامم المتحده عن حزمه مساعدات
للسودان قيمتها 200 مليون دولار
وسبعمائه مليون دولار لتغطيه الحاجات
الاساسيه من المواد الغذائيه والاساسيه
وكل ما نتوقع ان يحتاجه السكان في دارفور
تمكنا حتى الان من جمع مئتي مليون دولار
من احتياجات هذا العام والان نحن بحاجه
الى المزيد من الاموال بسبب تدعيه النزاع
خلال الاسابيع القليله الماضيه لكن ثمه
حاجه اولا لموافقه طرفي النزاع في السودان
حتى يتم ادخال المساعدات
الطرفين قبولي التوجه الى اي مكان في
السودان للقائهما او لقاء من ينوب عنهما
للتباحث بشان التزامات يجب على الطرفين
قبولها واهمها تعهدهما بضروره السماح
بايصال المساعدات للشعب السوداني كلا
الجنرلين ابديا استعدادا لتقديم مثل هذه
التعاقدات ونحن الان في خضم التباحث بشان
اليات عقد الاجتماعين مع الطرفين
يشدد على التزام الامم المتحده تجاه الشعب
السوداني ولا يفوته التعبير عن تقديره
لجهود المتطوعين والعاملين في المجال
الانساني
هذا مجال دونه معوقات كبيره وان خصصت له
موارد ماليه
طبيعي ان تسعى المنظمه الدوليه لاخذ
ضمانات من جميع الاطراف بحمايه موظفيها
ووصول المساعدات الانسانيه
لكن مع استمرار المعارك قد يتعطل ذلك
المسعى او تبطئ وتيرته
وقد تطول جراء ذلك معاناه قطاعات حيويه في
السودان القى الاقتتال بظلال قاتمه عليها
نقابه اطباء السودان اعلنت خروج 61 مستشفى
من الخدمه في الخرطوم وحدها بسبب القتال
انها منظومه السودان الصحيه المشارفه على
الانهيار بفعل قصف المشافي ونفاد الادويه
وقبل الدواء تمت الغذاء فالى ما يمضي
الحال بالسودان وثلث سكانه كانوا قبل
اندلاع القتال يعتمدون في الاساس على
المساعدات الغذائيه
في جوانب الازمه الاخرى شحوا المياه
ومشتقات الوقود والقطاعات خدمات الكهرباء
بلغت ضرر قطاع التعليم مع اغلاق عشرات
الجامعات والاف المدارس في مناطق تتركز
فيها المواجهات المسلحه اما في الجانب
الاقتصادي فقد نظرت السيوله النقديه بفعل
نهب مصارف وتوقف معظمها عن العمل
لا تخفي الامم المتحده الحاجه لنحو مليار
ونصف المليار الدولار خلال العام الحالي
وحده في شكل مساعدات انسانيه لملايين
السودانيين يشمل ذلك من علق منهم في مناطق
القتال وكذا مئات الالوف ممن توزعت
مصائرهم بين نازح محليا وطالب لجوء وراء
الحدود
هذا واكد قائد القوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان حميدتي التزامه التام بفتح وحمايه
الممرات الانسانيه لتسهيل حركه المواطنين
وضمان وصول المساعدات الانسانيه وقال
احمدتي انه ناقش مع مفوض الامم المتحده
للشؤون الانسانيه
في السودان واهميه التنسيق لتقديم
المساعدات المطلوبه
وفي اخبارنا الاخرى قال الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيسي لسوريا تخطت مشاكل وعراقيل
كثيره ونجحت رغم التهديدات والعقوبات
المفروضه عليها وفق تعبيره اضاف رئيسي
خلال لقائه الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد في
دمشق ان تطورات اكلت صحه موقف بلاده تجاه
سوريا مشيرا الى ان بلاده ستواصل دعم
سوريا وداع رئيسي في مؤتمر صحفي من نظيره
السوري الولايات المتحده الى الخروج من
سوريا بشكل عاجل
مصرون على تعزيز التعاون مع سوريا ودول
المنطقه دون تدخلات اجنبيه الوجود الاجنبي
في المنطقه يفاقب الامن فيها والوجود
الامريكي في سوريا لن يجلب الامن لها بل
هو عامل لزعزعه الاستقرار فيها وفي
المنطقه على الامريكيين ان يخرجوا من
سوريا بشكل عاجل لاجل زمان الامن فيها
والسبيل لتحقيق الامن هو ان تبسط سوريا
سيادتها على جميع اراضيها
قالت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه ان
الفلسطينيه استشهد متاثرا بجروحه واصيب
خمسه نتيجه القصف الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه
فجر اليوم واتبنت فصائر المقاومه اطلاق
قضايا فصاروخيه باتجاه مستوطنات
الاسرائيليه تتاخم القطاع بعد دخول اتفاق
الوقفه اطلاق النار بينها وبين اسرائيل
حيز التنفيذ فجر اليوم
ضوء الصباح كشف الدمار الذي خلفه القصف
الاسرائيلي على مناطق واسعه في قطاع غزه
بعد اعلان وقف اطلاق النار معظم الغارات
الاسرائيليه استهدفت مواقع للمقاومه يمنع
تصويرها او اراضي زراعيه لكن الاكتضاض
السكاني في غزه جعل المناطق السكنيه
المحيطه بالاماكن المستهدفه عرضه للاضرار
وسقوط الضحايا
شفتها من الباب يعني وايش يبعد عنك انا
وبنتي نرجس ساعه واحنا طب هذا الوضع يعني
انا دائما فيه دائما من 2008 لهلقيت فش فش
عنا حد يعني احنا ليش يعني هذا الوضع
ماساوي بدنا رعب الاطفال خافوا وانا قلت
ماتوا اللي في الدار ماتوا ولادي وحال صرت
اصرخ يا فلان وينك
تعود الحياه تدريجيا في المناطق التي
تضررت من القصف الاسرائيلي لكن ذلك لا
يعني انتهاء معاناه سكان القطاع اذ يخشى
الناس ان يتعرضوا مجددا وفي اي وقت للقصف
محاولات الحكومه الاسرائيليه الاستمرار
العبث في سواعق التفجير في المشهد
الفلسطيني وفي الساحه الفلسطينيه مستمره
تهديدات والترويح بمزيد من تصدير الازمات
داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه الى المشهد
الفلسطيني لا تزال قائمه ويبدو اننا امام
مزيد من التصعيد خلال المرحله القادمه اذا
ما استمرت هذه الحكومه الفاشيه في محاولات
العبث في المشهد الفلسطيني قد تكون هذه
الجوله من التصعيد الميداني في قطاع غزه
انتهت بتدخل الوسطاء لكنها لم تنهي اسباب
اندلاعها او تخفف من المخاوف من نوايا
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه التي تنذر
بالمزيد من الازمات
ليل قطاع غزه كان عنيفا
سلسله غارات اسرائيليه امتدت لساعات ورد
الفصائل الفلسطينيه باطلاق صواريخ تجاه
المناطق والمستوطنات الاسرائيليه تواصل
حتى ساعات الفجر غضبا على استشهاد الشيخ
خضر عدنان المقاومه الفلسطينيه فرضت قواعد
اشتباك على في الصراع مع العدو الصهيوني
القصف سيقابله قصف الاعتداء سيقابله
اعتداء المقاومه الفلسطينيه لن تتردد لن
تستسلم ستقوم بواجباتها ومسؤولياتها وهي
في مواجهه مستمره لا يمكن ان تتوقف ولا
تنتهي الا بزوال الاحتلال
اعلان وقف اطلاق النار بواسطه عده اطراف
اوقفت تصعيد لكنه لم يتضمن الاشاره الى
امكانيه تسليم جثمان الشهيد او حتى
التخفيف من الاجراءات العقابيه عن الاسرى
في السجون الاسرائيليه هبه الجزيره من
مدينه غزه
[موسيقى]
بالعوده للهجوم الذي اعلن عنه الكريم
اليوم الذي يعيد الى الواجهه دور المسيرات
في تغيير موازين المعارك ومفهوم الحروب
هذا التغيير الذي يصنفك احد ابرز التحولات
الجيوسيه منذ عام 2010 مبني على عده عوامل
اولها سهوله تحرك هذه المسيرات وعدم حاجه
المتحكم فيها للتدريب الطويل كالطائرات
التقليديه وهذا بطبيعه الحال ينسحب على
جاهزيتها للهبوط في اي موقع دون الحاجه
الى مدرج هبوط او تفاصيل تقنيه كثيره
لديها ايضا قدره على التجسس حيث تستطيع ان
تمسح وتصور الاماكن اماكن العدو وتقديمها
معلومات حيه مباشره عنها مع صعوبه رصدها
في كثير من الاحياء
تنخفض تكلفتها فمسيرات الكاميكاز هي
الانتحاريه مثلا المحمله بشحنه تفجيريه
تبلغ قيمتها نحو 20 الف دولار فقط ما يضع
عبء على الدور التي تريد الدفاع عن نفسها
اذ تبلغ كلفه التصدي لهذه المضادات
الارضيه اضعاف تكلفه الهجوم
المسيرات ايضا خلال العقد الماضي كانت
محوريه في العديد من النزاعات كسوريه
اليمن اذربيجان ارمينيا اوكرانيا وليبيا
تحديدا في اذربيجان في المثال اقليم
ايضا هذه العوامل دفعت دول العالم الى رفع
الانفاق على هذه
المسيرات في بنود انفاقها العسكري لتجاوز
30 مليار دولار عام
2022 لكن هذه المسيرات تنقسم الى فئات حسب
وزنها وسرعتها ومهمتها ومن ابرزها فئه فئه
بوزن 150 كيلو جراما او اقل تستخدم لمهام
الاستطلاع او المراقبه او ايصال الذخائر
طبعا من اشهرها الطائرات
وذلك ايضا فئه ثانيه هي فئه الهجوميه
الانتحاريه تعتبر المسيره الايرانيه شاهد
من الامثله عليها اذ حضرت اسمها كثيرا في
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ويصل وزنها الى
200 كيلو جرام وتبلغ كلفه انتاجها حوالي
20 الف دولار فقط الفئه الثالثه تستخدم في
الهجمات ويمكنها التحليق لمده 24 ساعه ومن
اشهرها المسيره التركيه
بيرقدار تي في 2 وتكلفه الواحده منها ما
بين مليون وخمسه ملايين وقامت بير خضار
بادوار بارزه في المعارك في كل من
اوكرانيا واثيوبيا وارمينيا
الفئه الاخيره التي نستحضرها اليوم
فتتجاوز حمولتها 600 كلغ هي الاخطر بسبب
المهام الموكله اليها من اشهرها طبعا
المسيره الامريكيه ام كيو
وقد تم استخدامها من قبل واشنطن في قصف
العراق وافغانستان
للحديث عن هذه المسيرات
والتغيير الذي جلبته للحروب في مختلف
انحاء العالم ينضموا الينا
رئيس قسم المخاطر العالميه في مركز جنيف
لسياسه الامن طبعا نحن نتحدث عن المسيرات
ولا نقول
وهذا من المهم تاكيده ولا نقول بان ما حدث
على الكرملين اليوم هو فقط وفق الروايه
الروسيه هجوم اوكرانيا على الكرملين لكن
فيما فيما عدا ذلك فيما عدا حادثه
الكرملين
المسيرات كيف غيرت الحرب
في الحقيقه بشكل اساسي الطائرات المسيره
بدات بالاستعمال في فيتنام في حرب فيتنام
لاهداف استطلاعيه ومعها مرور الوقت
استحوذت على مهام جديده خصوصا هجمات
التي نفذت من خلال استخدام هذه السبل
البسيطه وكان هناك استهداف بعد الحادي عشر
من سبتمبر لايقاده من القاعده من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لاغتيالهم
بهذه الطرق الدقيقه والان كما استعرضتم في
تقريركم هناك في تقريركم هناك طرق مختلفه
تستخدم من خلالها هذه المسيرات هل هنالك
مهام لا يمكن ان تسند للطائرات المسيره
نعم بكل تاكيد الامر يتوقف على نوعي وعلى
طبيعتي المهام التي نتحدث عنها على سبيل
المثال القصف العنيف لا يمكن ان تنفذه
المسيرات بعد لم تصل الى هذه المرحله ولكن
ما شاهدناه في السنوات الخمس وست الماضيه
استخدام
المسيرات في اسراب اذا هناك سلسله من
الهجمات التي تستهدف عددا من الاهداف ومع
تطور الذكاء الاصطناعي نحن نشهد بشكل
متزايد استخدام المسيرات التي لديها نوع
من الاستقلاليه في اتخاذ القرار في العام
2020 لربما كان هناك تقارير اشارت الى
قدره المسيرات التركيه على تنفيذ عمليه
اغتيال بطريقه مستقله ولكن هذا جزء مهم من
عمل المسيرات وهناك تطوير لهذا المجال
بالضبط هنالك عمليه اغتيال كثيره حدثت
بالمسيرات لكن ما حدث في الكرملين اليوم
يمكن ان يدخل ضمن عمليات الاغتيال وفقه
المهام السابقه
لعمليات الاغتيال التي نفدتها مسيرات سواء
في اليمن او في افغانستان او في العراق او
في غيرها
كما ذكرتم من غير الواضح ما حصل في
الكرمله اليوم كنت اتحدث عن الاستقلاليه
في اتخاذ القرارات ولكن هناك في العام
2019 ما حصل مع مادورو لقد تفلت من محاوله
او نجم من محاوله اغتيال وفي العام 2021
رئيس مجلس الوزراء الكاظمي العراقي ايضا
نجا من محاوله اغتيال نفذت من خلال طائره
مسيره وبالتالي نرى هذا النوع من العمليات
ينتشر والجديد في هذا العامل هو ان
المسيرات كما ذكرتم هي رخيصه الثمن يمكن
ان يتم تصنيع الطائرات المسيره من قبل
جهات متعدده ليس بالضروره ان تكون دولا
وبالتالي تستخدم هذه المسيرات بشكل متزايد
في المستقبل لتنفيذ عمليه مماثله كتلك
العمليه التي نفذت اليوم كيف ستتطور هذه
المسيرات في المستقبل وكيف سيتطور ايضا
انظمه تتطور انظمه الدفاع ضدها
ما نراه في مجال تصنيع المسيرات هو ان
الجهات من غير الدول تستعمل المسيرات ولكن
هناك ايضا دول من مثلي تركيا واسرائيل
لديها تقدم كبير في تصنيع المسيرات الصين
كذلك كدوله لديها تصنيع كبير للمسيرات
واستخدمت في اوكرانيا وايضا استخدمت في
الماضي المسيرات من قبل القاعده اما
بالنسبه الى مواجهه هذه التهديدات وصدي
الهجمات المنفذه من قبل المسيرات ليس
بالامر السهل نحن بحاجه الى نظام شامل
الرخيص من حيث التكلفه نشكرك شكرا جزيلا
من جنيف جون ماركلي رئيس قسم المخاطر
العالميه في مركز جنيفر سياسه الامن